[Music]
hey what's going on
eric cortina here so as you guys know
the machine has been set up
and now it's ready to run one problem
i don't know how to run it so today
we're going to start training
me so that i can learn how to run this
thing
so dmg mori offers training
and obviously i opted to get it because
i've never ran this machine so they sent
a very qualified
uh trainer to train me and he's gonna
train me for three days
and after those three days hopefully
i'll be able to make chips on my
own i'm pretty sure i'll be making chips
on my own
so anyway uh he's on the way i'm gonna
go fire it up the generator
fire the machine and hopefully have it
ready by the time he gets here
[Music]
all right it's happening i see the power
company out there
changing out poles so
we're getting closer
[Music]
so
my
warning this machine design
and manufacture for well-trained
operators who have basic knowledge of
machine operation do not
operate this machine unless this applies
to you
to avoid accidents well i'm not well
trained
but i'm gonna be
all right
here it is
ready to go so this is where the
lubrication oil goes
i have the pump for uh for a hose uh
wash down this is the motor it's not
plugged in if i need to i can plug it in
here
hook up the hose here and then run it to
the front
this is uh hydraulics hydraulics so this
is where i'm gonna
put oil if i'm if i'm running low on
hydraulics yes
and then this is the cooler for the oil
chucks or the for the for the chucks
right
and uh this is going to be a 32
hydraulic hole
32 hydraulic oil okay we're good don't
blow
air don't blow this over there use the
host
because air will blow chips under the
under the
cover under the weight covers
everything and you'll end up with
shavings packed up in the bedway
okay we also have if you ever do
specialty metals
you have a copper liner that can go in
the parts catcher oh okay
but you have teflon in there right now
so i think that's fine this is the parch
catcher itself
oh i see what you're saying so you're
lined and teflon in here
and then i adjust the length just oh
there's a set screw here
and this is how i adjust where i want it
yes okay
and then from there it's just
programmable okay perfect
all right so michael just gave me a uh
old machinist trick
which is what old school so if you're on
your lathe and you're getting a little
chatter on your bar
keep your back screws tight but back off
on the front screw
and then slightly snug it and it'll
dampen the vibration in your boring bar
how much you snug it right yes so you
just gotta
listen to where listen to it cut and
just slowly tweak that a little
bluetooth a little tighter to where it's
just putting pressure
on the bar and it'll absorb the so
so you're tuning the vibration on the
bar
with that with the last screw on the
block you know how else you can do that
[Music]
so it's a tuner so using that as a tuner
cool man all right so we are setting up
this uh
this drill clearance is clearance right
michael
stay into of mile
i got michael here he's training me and
of course god with tangolo is here as
well
giving us a hand with all this uh
craziness
but uh we got can you back the thing off
so i can show what's going on here
[Music]
do not index the turret right now
why not all right so we got some tools
in here so far
this is a quarter a three quarter inch
drill
that i'm going to use for my easy tuners
it is not going to go there
it's actually going to go in a dedicated
holder with cooling through but
we don't have that bushing yet so we
just put it in here just so we can
kind of play around with the offsets and
all that good stuff
uh but you know you see i'm gonna be
able to have four
different bars in there i'm gonna have
boring bars and id threading bars in
this holder
of course we have a drill here we have
my tap for the
od let me uh let me show you what's
going on
so to make this easy tuner right we need
to drill
and tap these holes around the perimeter
so that's the drill
that's the tap this one's going to be
the angled uh
holder for uh for the muzzle brake to do
the angle
uh ports it's not set yet right now it's
set that way but it's going to actually
be facing
this way this one is going to be another
end mill that's gonna do the straight
slots on the uh
muscle brake and the side this is the
one that's gonna be
the boring board this one's cooling
through it's gonna it's double sided so
i'll put one here
and then another one here yeah i'm sorry
that's for the drills
this is going to be my cut off uh holder
this is going to be the one cutting off
the part
i don't have the obviously i don't have
it in here yet but that's what that's
for
of course this is my roughing and
turning tools this is going to be a
rougher
this is going to be the finishing
cutting you know the nice finish this
one does the heavy work this one just
does the pretty work
[Music]
and of course now we have this one which
is an axial i'm going to have
a if i want to do any milling or
anything
on the face of the part for example if i
was making this
collet right here and i needed a drill
or
tap these holes or whatever uh that's
what
this one would do it would be it would
kind of more likely do
here offset and they would drill that
and then the turret would turn
or the collet that the spindle would
turn and index and do that one and that
one so that's what this one's for
and it's double sided it can do this
side and this side
and then we have another one over here
that we're probably going to do
uh deburring with this one
and then this is gonna be for my od
threading tools gonna be in here
to do the threads on the outside and
then we have another
empty spot so that's what we have so far
as you can imagine there's a lot of
planning that needs to go into this
to get all your tools in position and uh
now you understand why i did this and
the double holders right because
i only have one station left if i didn't
do four here
i would run out of room if i tried to do
just one in every holder
i would be out of room so that's the
reason you want to do stuff like that
you really want to plan this
uh ahead and you're probably still gonna
get it wrong but at least you're going
to get that much closer
but so far so good now
the other way you can do this is you can
do a setup for every tool for example so
if you're going to do this
then i don't need that many tools you
can do the setup for this tool
for this part and then once you get it
set up then you can run a lot of parts
and then once you change to another part
then you can break down your whole setup
and rearrange it for the next part
obviously i don't want to do that i want
to have it set up
my parts are pretty simple the only one
that's more complicated
is the brake right so
having said all that i want to have this
machine set up
so that i can run the brake or the
tuners or whatever
without having to change my setup one
way i'm doing that
uh which i've been doing for long see
i've been doing all this on a manual
lathe and mill right so this all came
about
with manual machines whenever you do
manual machines
changing tools is a pain so i
standardize all my stuff so
all my tuners have 10 32 holes or screws
around the perimeter
because of that i should never have to
change the drill and the tap
other than for wear right so those
should stay in there forever
unless i do something crazy and i want
to change it but those should stay there
forever all the
the the ports on this muzzle brake
they're all the same size and everything
so all my
end mills stay there same size same
everything so
standardizing your tools is huge
because you don't have that much room so
whenever i design my parts i try to use
the same tool for
all the parts so that i don't have to be
changing
my setup and again i did that back when
i was doing it with the manual
machines now that i come to a big cnc
lathe
it's still usable because there's only
so much real estate
on the turret unless you want to break
down your setup every time
which i don't want to do anyway that's
what's going on here
michael's been extremely helpful uh very
knowledgeable guy
and of course god with tungloin he
brings me all these goodies
look at this all these tools are gonna
go in that machine
at some point and every tool that goes
on here
we have to touch it off we bring down
the uh
the probe and then we just touch the
tools off and all that good stuff so
that's what we're doing and we have
we're only doing this side
this turret holds tools on this side as
well for the sub spindle
after we're done with all these then
we're going to do all these and we have
to put another
probe and this uh in here so
it takes quite a bit of time to do all
this but
once it's set up it should be done and
now we can run parts
like a lot of parts hopefully oh man
it's been a long day you guys see
anything
pretty dark out here
oh somewhere light switch here we go
all right so let me tell you what's
going on here i had to leave
earlier as someone to be so
right after training i have to leave
the machine is pretty much ready to make
some parts
uh we're probably going to make an easy
tuner just a standard dc tuner
we programmed half of it uh the main
spindle
side the sub spindle i'm still waiting
on some tools to come in
so i don't have all the tools for the
sub spindle
i have the majority of the tools but not
all of them so
that's what's going on but the machine
needs coolant
so this is the coolant we're going to
use
what is it i don't i don't know anything
about coolant to tell you the truth but
this is what uh i got
from the place where i'm getting my
tools they said it was a hybrid coolant
whatever that means so that's what we're
going to use that's what they
recommended okay
i don't have any water to this building
so i'm using
these buckets right here
so those buckets are about
i don't know i'm gonna say two and a
half gallons and three so i'm doing
about five to six gallons
each trip
and this machine takes 55 gallons
so it's gonna be quite a few trips but
somebody has to do it right anyway uh
that's what i want to work on right now
and uh
michael's coming back tomorrow for more
training
uh i've learned quite a bit about this
machine you know how to run it and all
that but
i mean we're only scratching the surface
i mean this thing can pretty much do
anything but i'm just learning enough to
get it
going get it running and just so i can
turn out some parts for you guys
uh i don't know if you could tell but
i'm a bit tired
but it has to get done so i'm gonna get
it done
so we go outside and we see leroy over
here working
leroy brought all the pipe for the
electrical
leroy leroy leroy
you should probably put it over there
somewhere over there that's where we're
gonna use it
oh yeah i'm just gonna put it to be the
way right now i'll just put it over
there
because right now i'm about to start
using that stuff
all right yeah leroy anyway uh this is
all the pipe for the electrical
the underground all this
and uh
all this stuff this is all my panels
everything everything that needs to
happen to get
electrical to the building is here uh if
you guys see off in the distance
they're replacing all those electrical
poles so
it's getting closer they're already
working on that and of course i have
my pole right here this is the pole so
now i can start trenching
trench all the way here put all my
panels in the building so
it's getting there it's getting there
of course none of this matters to you at
this point because
if you're waiting for a break you still
don't have one right
all this i call this the rule well i
don't call it but
there's something called the rule of the
last mile which means that
all this that i've been doing for the
last six weeks
eight weeks actually i don't even know
but all this that i've been doing for
the last
however long since you ordered your
break you know
figuring out a machine to get you know
doing the floors in the shop doing the
electrical talking to a million
different people
ordering the machine getting the machine
set up all that all that that
all the sleepless nights that i've gone
through none of that matters to you
until you have your break in your hand
right that's the rule of the last mile
right
until i do that last mile which is
shipping the break to you
nothing matters so
don't worry i'm still out here working
really really hard
to get that brake in your hand but this
is what's going on
things are finally finally seems like
they're starting to
get some traction uh this is the
compressor that i bought
i put it inside the building it lasted
one day
[Applause]
you guys were absolutely right this
thing's freaking loud in there
so we threw it outside at some point
we're gonna have a slab here hopefully
very soon
and then all this is going to be out
here all the panels are going to go
there
but anyway just giving you an update of
what's going on here
like i said the power company is working
hard over there so
we're getting that much closer and if
you've been following along
again you already know this but i really
appreciate you thank you
you